welcome to this video brings better 08
so wyd see playing a bit more v45
recently I'm not so much Sicilians we
are this is this line it's actually
somewhat tricky is this line it's not
super grade or anything for white but
it's always yeah I always have to
remember the moves night before at this
d6 i think is right i forgot that maybe
the success right there relics can be
dangerous now Knight a5 neither 5 coming
maybe mmm no whoa yeah that's what white
is playing for with this this line for
some trickery here ok d6s knight c6
let's go Bishop e7 I thought night at
five instead of 93 would have been
better actually but
hmm
yeah looky eight Bishop g5 this kind of
business we should be fine i couldn't
really do anything else
okay i'm probably going to get brilliant
bone structure maybe you can go nite h6
or something like that night age six
takes rook e8 queen aid we should have
six okay yeah I have no hm
what is this by the way to materialise
I'm a porn up very strong pawns okay he
really has wants to take their hmm I
could play like d5 push the pawns yeah
maybe 85 and c5
hey I should have played Queenie FOIA
just get rid of the Queen's they're
really not sure about this position I
mean structural structure looks bad but
two bishops against two nights not too
bad at least he's taking some time
typical mo of people playing this kind
of lines is just to play instant moves
all the time but not not this one I came
so let's go here his background is weak
so he cannot play I'm group d three or
something something like that mmm that
really well placed there something like
D for Bishop to Queen c6 coming
yeah 26 assault song is really taking
ages here okay so d44 closes the
position somehow how I can I wonder not
sure about this if I want to replay do
for him + d 4 then I can ok d3s is a
threat some okay let's do it I'll
threaten it's an idea let's let's say
okay 40 p 1 and i didn't see that one
coming hmm Queenie for maybe not sure
about this Queenie for takes takes I
wonder if Bishop before as a move that's
a somewhat strange move but maybe rookie
one Bishop d3 wins hmm interesting move
let's try my dears also Queenie 5 and
still be three I know I can check that
was that was helpful so there's
something better than taking their even
I mean it's sitting in a pin so
it is also not particularly easy this
one may be attacking f5 I don't see him
getting out of the pin so what ideas to
take on e2 and then played III yeah yeah
I do let's do that 93 now should be age
six something time where he loved to go
f5 said principal and I'm thinking a bit
too long from a practical point of view
here 5j I could have probably just win
one easily on time by playing instant
moves but check okay I wanted to check
really flesh well which probably really
failed yeah I'd probably feel too
miserably okay let's enter
anyway to enter the position no I know I
can go III check check check hmm like
four fins on time well that wasn't good
nope not not a very well technical play
I really didn't see that he can just get
get to d3 and I made a big mistake in
the opening at leiden that line Nia is
is notoriously tricky it it's not good
but it is tricky I think here you go d6
if i'm not mistaken or am I wrong I
think this is the move and then he goes
back Teague stinks this this is how it
is usually played and i played this
immediately and it felt felt difficult I
was more afraid of that move instead of
Knight c3 I don't know it looks very
annoying maybe I'm okay with now that
you kind of you have the worst pawn
structure ever now but it's okay i can
go like Queen hierba should be seven or
something I Queen first and then the
bishop here and I'm very well
centralized this is ok so
yeah this looks really awful but yeah
two bishops against two nights and he
still has to think about that porn a
form i was surprised that he
decentralized his night the pond of like
it would be there for taking any in any
case but care pushed those pawns oh
that's a big mistake he can he could
have gone here and i can basically
resign didn't see that tactic made on g7
hmm and I could have played this one
winning a piece this is funny it wins
apiece this is a threat and then taking
here yeah wins apiece and he has no way
out here i'm setting up a pin wow so
instead of winning i I wanted to lose
and now the game continues and ce4
computer gives age 3 with a huge
advantage hmm don't ask me why 93 may be
coming yeah deform queen e6 was winning
I checking here and Bishop before so I
had this is basically aya and say i
winna winna tempo here and then i play
that move very good young but ok he
stumbled check into this and now queen
d6 was a was a simpler win somehow don't
quite get it what exactly is coming this
and then then i'm taking and going d
three or something uh probably yeah yeah
that
wasn't the best way to do it yeah I was
very eager of getting f5 in and that way
her when Jack gave away that porn chan
chan check Jim it's probably maybe this
is really a draw there are some
breakthrough ideas with the with e3 and
things I am this is I wanted to prepare
you three the computer actually gives
this move directly as winning with the
black king taking stuff now okay I
wanted to prepare that check yeah so
that does wish I check I'm still winning
here I wasn't sure in the game I hear
hear karen luke is a pretty strong piece
especially compared to the light in the
end game yeah this is the the engine
landed it picks up all the pawns I
wasn't entirely sure when I was when I
saw it the in the game but it seems to
be win okay thanks for watching